Marxism leninism ideology is being
pumped into the soft heads of of of at
least three generations of American
students we have been ideologically
conditioned for the past 10 years to
think that really at this point only our
choices are only Trump or some sort of
racial woke mind muddled Democrat those
are the choices we've been given at a
national level between the Republicans
and the Democrats we must break this
cycle because this cycle is leading us
to society collapse it actually is and
guess what there was a guy who did a
video about 40 years ago explaining how
another country was trying to infiltrate
us to create societal collapse his his
name is Yuri bezman of have I shown you
a video of him let's try it again
ideological subversion that is a phrase
that uh I'm afraid some Americans don't
fully understand when uh the Soviets use
the phrase ideological subversion what
do they mean by it ideological
subversion is is the slow process which
we call either ideological subversion or
active
measures in the language of of the KGB
or psychological warfare what it
basically means is to change the
perception of reality of every
American to such an extent that despite
of the abundance of
information no one is able to come to
sensible
conclusions in the interest of Defending
themselves their families their
community and their
country it's a great
brainwashing uh process which goes very
slow and it's divided in in four basic
stages uh the first one being
demoralization it takes from 15 to 20
years to demoralize a nation why that
many years because this is the minimum
number of years which requires to
educate one generation of students in
the country of of of your enemy exposed
to the ideology of the enemy in other
words Marxism leninism ideology is being
pumped into the soft heads of of of at
least three generations of American
students without being challenged or
counterbalance by the basic values of
americanism okay I know we've shown you
portions of that before and we will
continue show to show you portions of it
because it is explaining what has
happened in America and what has led us
to this very moment right now this very
moment moment which as I said at the top
of the show we are starting to wake up
to and a whole bunch of people are now
pushing back on but if you take the
basic ideas like America isn't good and
you teach that to a generation uh that
the country was founded on racism and
you teach that for a generation or two
that 2 plus 2 doesn't equal four and you
teach that for a while that having a
penis has nothing to do with being a boy
and you teach that for a while etc etc
you could see how you'd end up in a
place where we would be in this constant
state of Hysteria that we seem to be
in